CNN an anchor Don Lemon is out after 17
years Don Lemon stunned after being Let
Go by CNN this following months of
controversy for the longtime news anchor
what happened there because it seemed
like he had weathered another storm I
was not very surprised to see Don Lemon
removed at CNN in fact what surprised me
was that he was able to stay there for
so long but over at the network The
Source tells E.T everyone is floored
with another Insider adding that Don's
now former colleagues found out in real
time when the news broke so I want to
step back for a moment and take a quick
look at how we got here that was done
just hours before he learned he was
being let go on Monday morning he's been
with the atlanta-based news outlet for
17 years it was pretty clear that new
management was not going to be a fan of
Don Lemon they gave him a shot in the
morning and now clearly this is more
than a demotion it was a termination in
a statement to staffers obtained by E.T
the network says Don will forever be a
part of the CNN family we wish him well
and will be cheering him on in future
Endeavors Don on the other hand didn't
seem to take the news Well saying on
Twitter I would have thought that
someone in management would have had the
decency to tell me directly I think it's
a tough tough position to be in in
another twist CNN hopped on Twitter to
respond calling his claim inactive and
alleging he was given an opportunity to
meet with higher ups meanwhile another
source tells E.T the Network's offer it
came after Don learned he was let go so
he didn't see the need for a sit down
CNN is saying well if Don had wanted to
he could have come into the office and
had a meeting with management maybe don
did not want to have that so he decided
to go public instead of course Don's
bombshell exit comes after a marathon of
controversy like variety's expose citing
sources that say for two decades the 57
year old exhibited troubling treatment
of women and unprofessional Antics in
response Don claimed the story was made
up of patently false anecdotes Don Lemon
was clearly hurt by that recent Scandal
yeah remember when Don was temporarily
he pulled off the air in February after
this comment about former Governor Nikki
Haley if you look if you Google when is
a woman in her prime it'll say 20s 30s
and 40s are you talking about Prime for
like child preparing
and yes the presidential hopeful saw
Monday's news resharing a campaign
slogan inspired by the feud past my
Prime hold my beer I've set across from
him countless times and I know he's a
really talented broadcaster so I think
he's going to have a number of options
out there and thank you for joining us
this morning CNN news Central starts
right after this break I have no idea
who will be in line for the CNN Morning
Show chair but I can tell you this if I
were in charge I wouldn't fill it I
would have Poppy Harlow and Caitlin
Collins lead the show by themselves it
doesn't really matter who the anchor is
what matters that CNN is on top of the
news and so that's why I believe it's
going to remain strong
[Music]
thank you